in this video i am going to talk about t
cell activation suppose
our body is invaded by a pathogen here
you can see
along with this nail some blue colored
pathogen entered in our body
and just beneath the skin layer we have
dendritic cell we have macrophages they
will sense this pathogen invasion and
they will take them up
say for instance the dendritic cell will
take this pathogen up and this dendritic
cell
will go through the capillary to the
lymph node
so in this lymph node there are two type
of immune cells the t cells and the b
cells so this dendritic cell first will
activate t cell and thereby they will
elicit the immune response and further
t cells could activate b cells in this
video we will
take a look how
t cells are activated by the dendritic
cells so inside this lymph node there is
a specific t cell region where the t
cell resides so here you can see
in the lymph node we have our t cells
so we just want to take a look at the
surface of the t cell
so in the surface of the t cell
we have the t cell receptor it's a big
complex it has a alpha chain it has a
beta chain it has delta and epsilon
chain it has a gamma and epsilon chain
it has
some integrins
some adhesive molecules lfa1 and cd2 and
they have some core receptor also like
cd28 and cd40 ligand cd40 ligand is
essential for b cell activation but for
t cell activation we will take a look
about at the role of cd28 and cd28 is
essential for t cell activation so here
we can see
there is a dendritic cell
trying to activate our t cell so t cell
activation essentially need three
signals signal one signal two and signal
three
so the signal 1 comes from the mhc
the signal 1 comes from the mhc and the
tcr
interaction the dendritic cell
chewed up the pathogen and displayed its
antigen onto a class 2 mhc and this
class 2 mhc can be recognized by the t
cell and the
t cell will generate signal 1 upon
activation and the second second signal
for activation comes from the cd28
which is present on the t cell surface
and the b7 which is also called cd80 or
cd86 and this interaction gives the
second signal for activation
another signal comes from the
interleukin
so for example interleukin 2 secreted by
the dendritic cell can also help in the
t cell activation here you can see that
t cell have certain interleukin
receptors and the il2 can bind to this
receptors and elicit the third signal
all these three signals are essential
for t cell activation without
a signal without any one of these signal
t cell activation is incomplete and
this also corresponds correspond to
their functionality without the three
signals t cell is not fully function
not fully functional
now
there are two other interactions here
one is lfa1 icam lfa1 is present on the
t cell surface icam is present on the
dendritic cell surface this interaction
and the cd 2 and cd58 interaction
strengthens this interaction between
dendritic cell and t cell thus they have
a indirect role in the activation so
once this t cell is activated this t
cell
is activated you can see and this t cell
could activate further
b cells
or these c t cells
could uh
activate b cells and t cells can also
go and attack certain
cells which are actually viral infected
so in that case the t cell would be cd8
type of t cell so
that's all about
thank you please like subscribe